let me introduce trying to take as
little time as possible
uh karen macrish who is going to tell us
about
the constraint programming perspective
of
um and coding
so karen well i think all the
information is here karen is from
uh university of glasgow and he has done
interesting work in constrained
programming
subgraph finding uh click solvers right
you're going to talk about
in in a couple of weeks in another
workshop in the beyond
that workshop and
um okay i shouldn't take any more of
your time but i'm really happy that you
could
speak here and tell us about constrained
programming perspective please
thanks so this is uh more of an overview
i'll be
fairly informal for most of this i'm
just trying to
hopefully give people an idea of some of
the interesting questions i think
might be worth working on so
modern constraint programming looks a
bit like the following we have
sets of variables that take values from
finite domains
these domains are potentially very large
for example
inter even float if somebody's being
particularly nasty to you
um it's quite common to have a few very
large variables and a lot of relatively
small or zero one variables in the model
we go even further most constraint
programming solvers natively support
step variables so you can represent a
set of integers
as a variable and at least in the high
level modeling languages we can
sometimes talk about
okay give me a partition of partial
functions between sets of integers
again some solvers even understand these
natively
and we like to work with what we call
global constraints which are expressed
declaratively
so given a set of variables i might say
all these variables must be different
and there are weighted generalizations
of this so
i might say you can use this value two
times you can use this value three times
and so on
if we want to talk about knapsack
problems we would just write knapsack as
a constraint
another example is saying okay if a
sequence of variables must match the
following
regular expression this is very useful
for
workforce allocation for shift pattern
scheduling and so on
now we have notions like sliding
cumulative sums which are used for
machine capacity and fuel in vehicles
and so on
the modern constraint programming view
of a constraint is
a constraint is something that has an
algorithm that can
delete values from variables domains
now this is called inference and the
whole process of seeing how many vari
how many values we can delete is called
propagation
the theoretical view of constraint
programming is often quite different so
theory papers often talk about binary
constraint satisfaction problems
and in this case constraints involve
exactly two variables
and constraints are usually expressed as
an explicit list of allowed
or forbidden pairs so this is where the
notion of
consistency comes from
a basic notion of consistent we say
constraint is arc
consistent if we pick any value from
either of its variables and we can look
in the
other variable and we can find a value
that would support this assignment
so what this means is that every value
left in the variables of domains in the
constraint
is present in at least one solution to
the constraint
we say a subproblem is arc consistent if
all of its constraints are arc
consistent
and the intuitive reason for why this is
interesting is
if the only thing you're allowed to do
is look at one constraint at a time
and the only thing you can do with a
constraint is delete
values and variables then arc
consistency
is the strongest possible reasoning you
can do
over binary constraint satisfaction
problems
it's a simple example this is kind of
pigeon holy so it's been discussed a lot
already
i'll just go over this very quickly uh
let's say we have three variables
each take a value zero one we want them
to be not equal so we're trying to to
color a triangle
uh if we look at what arc consistency
would do
on the problem expressed this way you
would look at the
x1 is not equal to x2 constraints and it
would check for each value whether it's
supported by another value so if
x1 is 0 we can give x2 for value 1 if x1
is 1 we can give a value
x2 equals 0 and so on and we can go
through all this check the definition
everything is fine we have no inference
nothing is deleted
but obviously to a human they the
problem is
very clearly unsatisfiable
so modern constraint programming uh
wants to go
beyond this in fact what we want to do
is
something a bit like how humans solve
sudoku puzzles so i'm showing you here
one row of a sudoku puzzle yes
what does supported mean um
there is a value that exists
such that um
the um so your your ver if you give a
variable its value and you give v of a
variable in the constraintness of a
value
um then you're okay uh
so if i say that a is not equal to b
if i give a value 1 to a then that is
supported by giving the value
0 to b okay thanks
okay but does this or consisted like a
global property or is it with respect to
some
partial assignment that you have already
started fiddling with
it can be with respect to whatever is
left in domains
so the um the theoretical view of what
solver is doing is when it branches you
can think of it as adding
constraints that's for surprising the
branching condition
and maintaining our consistency would
then somehow be pruning
values that so that for everything in
every domain and if you have a
constraint and you can find something in
the other domain that makes sense
yep
okay um so a sudoku example so
here we have nine variables i'm just
writing out the values that are present
in the domain so assume we've already
done some reasoning
so we have a variable with values one
eight a variable of value two three
another variable the value two three and
so on
and we have a constraint which in modern
constraint programming terms we would
call
all different over these nine variables
so what a human would do oh and i would
do this interactively if we weren't
using zoom
they would often say hey look that value
one only appears in one place so
obviously it has to go in the first box
they would look and see
okay we've got a 2 3 and a 2 3.
so we don't know which of these two
variables takes a value 2 and which
takes the value 3
but we do know that we can't use the
value 2 in any other place and we can't
use the value three
in any other place so we would do some
deletions
then we see we have these three
variables that have the three values
four five six between them
so we can't use four five six anywhere
else
and then we have a seven eight nine um
three variables and three values between
them but those don't occur anywhere else
and what i claim is this is the maximum
possible amount of
inference you can do if all you're
allowed to do now
is look at this single constraint
so this is what brings us to generalized
art consistency which is
also called domain consistency and is
sometimes just called
arc consistency so the idea is now you
can
pick any value from any variable present
in a constraint
and you want to find a way of giving
every other variable in the constraints
a value from its domain so sort of
constraint is satisfied
and for the all different constraints it
turns out if we know we're dealing with
all different constraints
we can do this in polynomial time we can
do exactly what humans do on sudoku
puzzles in polynomial
time this is a practical algorithm there
is a very long paper on how to
implement this cons employment's
algorithm incrementally etc
and this really pays off for some
problems if you have a solver that can
do this
you can solve for example very large
sudoku problems very quickly that if you
don't do this kind of reasoning then
they would take you
forever to solve
this is this is kind of the motivation
behind constraint programming these days
is these
uh global constraints and these
propagation algorithms that can do
very strong inference for us
so what about linear inequalities that
we're hearing a lot about
uh the pseudo boolean people in the uh
the south side of
the program the the slack algorithm that
you might know for
uh zero one integer linear inequalities
also works for
arbitrary integer domains in a fairly
easy way
and what it will do it will only ever
alter the
upper and lower bounds of variables it
won't ever poke holes in the middle of a
domain
we have another notion of consistency
called uh integer bounds consistency
usually just called
bounds consistency well now instead of
saying
pick an arbitrary value from a domain
we're saying
pick either the upper or lower bound
from a domain
and then there exists support across the
remainder of the constraint
um the reason we're interested is there
are much faster propagation algorithms
for some constraints
for some constraints achieving bounce
consistency
is easy or linear time or log linear
time whereas achieving
uh generalized out consistency can be
for example cubic or even
np-complete another reason this is
interesting is because if we
know that we're only ever going to be
doing bounce consistent propagation on a
particular variable
we can represent a variable just by
storing its upper and lower bounds so
two integer values this is very useful
if we have large domains
it's quite common in constraint
optimization problems for example for
the objective value to be an unbounded
integer
so if we can avoid storing two to the 64
values as explicit there um
zero one variables this is very helpful
what about linear equalities uh now in
this case
generalized out consistency of and
bounce consistency
are both np-hard you can see this
uh for example the subset pro sum
problem is
basically asking whether a solution
exists here
one thing we could do is enforce bounce
consistency on a pair
of inequalities
so if i have for example um
two x one plus two x two plus two x
three equals five and let's say the
values
uh v all take the values zero one or two
i could enforce that these have to be
greater than or equal to five and less
than or equal to five
uh this is uh integer bounds consistent
but the equality constraint is
is not bound consistent there are no
solutions to it so
um
what this is showing is um
bounce consistency on a pair of
inequalities is not the same
as bounds consistency on the equality
in practice enforcing bounds consistency
in this way is what a lot of constraint
programming solvers do
some solvers will also try to enforce
consistency anyway using a dynamic
programming type algorithm or something
called tabulation which i'll come to
later
but even though enforcing consistency on
a constraint might be np-complete this
doesn't necessarily stop us from doing
it
and something i think is is worth
pointing out um
something that i think the sat community
are not
very careful about but really matters
from a constraint programming
perspective is fits
the definition of consistency depends
very heavily upon how you represent your
constraints
so you can have consistency for a clique
of not equals to constraints versus
consistency for
all different and consistency when you
know you're dealing with an all
different constraint is stronger
two we saw two linear inequalities
versus one linear equality have
different notions
of consistency one of the things they
work with
it even depends upon how you express a
problem so for a subgraph mapping
problem we can talk about being
are consistent on vertices or are
consistent on edges and these mean
different things
so what about encodings so we say a cnf
encoding
is for example arc consistent if
unit propagation on the cnf
infers all of the deletions that arc
consistency
would infer on the original constraint
programming model
so in some sense we're saying that
we're taking a problem we're encoding it
in saturn we want
the reasoning that the sat solver can do
to be as
strong as the reasoning that a cp solver
would do if it is for example
maintaining arc consistency
and then a really interesting question
is uh
when is such an encoding possible um
we saw in the first talk and this is is
not possible for
uh pigeonhole type uh arguments the uh
all different constraint for example um
there is in some sense if you're allowed
to do
uh an organ uh an all different
propagator using an
arbitrary piece of code that runs in
polynomial time
you can do something that is is better
than any possible
uh polynomial space encoding for the all
different constraints
now in general we don't know uh which
constraints this is true for and which
constraints it is not true for
related this is a consistency for proof
logging
if we're working with a preflocking
system but it's built upon
reverse unit propagation uh we know
that okay we couldn't do uh deal
different constraints
but is it possible to justify
additional inferences that do not follow
using river cedar propagation in an
in in a compact and easy way
so for example if we're dealing with all
different constraints
we could use reverse unit propagation
plus generating new constraints on the
fly using the cutting points proof to
create a justifying constraint
programming solver
and again we don't know which
constraints we can and cannot do this
for
there's a trend in constraint
programming that constraint programming
solvers are becoming
very close to smt solvers these days so
there is
a desire to add learning etc into
constraint programming solvers
and a view that is becoming increasingly
popular in
australia is that we should not really
bother with clever constraint
propagation algorithms
we should not bother trying to delete as
many things as possible as early as
possible
instead we should wait until we hit a
conflict and then we should think really
carefully about
why we generated why we're in a conflict
and just start generating
causes later on to say
this particular constraint is not happy
with what you did for this very specific
reason
again it would be interesting to
understand why this
seems to work quite well in practice
we don't know in general when we should
use
stronger levels of consistency
generalized out consistency is not
always worth doing it can be
an expensive way of not getting very
many additional deletions
and sometimes even stronger levels of
consistency
pay off there is a notion of singleton
our consistency which is
where you can pick any variable pick any
value from its domain and then you can
make the entire problem
generalized are consistent subject to
that assignment um
yes so if i'm if i'm struggling to to
understand constraint programming is
because they only speak satis yep uh
is singleton or consistency kind of the
same thing as
probing
a variable and propagating yes
you can think of it as set a variable
and propagate and see whether
see whether something disappears
it is incredibly expensive to do
in practice it's in a sense it's running
one level of look ahead
across the entire solver and then seeing
if you can infer any deletions from this
sometimes this makes some very difficult
problems very very easy to solve
again we we don't know when or why we
should do this
another technique is something that's
called
auto tabulation the idea is you can
combine
multiple constraints that have an
overlap on their variables into
uh effectively a list of permitted
tuples so uh something like dnf
there's another one of these japanese
newspaper puzzles called some
skyscrapers that involves
uh linear inequalities sorry linear
equalities plus and all different
constraints
uh and if you look at every constraint
in
this problem and you combine constraints
for the ref of the same variable and
just
list out every possible solution to
the unified constraints then you can
solve these puzzles very very quickly
and in general there's a question of
when is it worth turning constraints
into
dnf or similar to
to end up with potentially an
exponentially sized encoding which still
runs fast in practice
another interesting topic that hasn't
received much attention from the theory
community as far as i know is
something we call failure-free
enumeration algorithms
we have a few examples of um
problems where if you want to enumerate
all solutions
well all you have to do is write an
algorithm that maintains a particular
level of consistency
and then it is guaranteed so you do a
simple backtracking search
whilst maintaining consistency and every
leaf node you can
you find then will definitely contain a
solution to the problem
an example of this is the stable
marriage problem
if you want to find all solutions
the simplest algorithm we know for doing
this is to write a constraint
programming algorithm that maintains
arc consistency uh just run it in a
backtrack
backtracking search and it says every
leaf node will be a solution so you will
never have
a failure i don't know if there's
something more interesting going on here
whether there is a
general notion of when this will work
and when it's worth looking at
and finally i thought i just very
briefly mentioned some other things we
can do when we have this
global constraint structure so when we
really know about the structure of our
global constraints
there's a lot of work on putting local
search inside constraint programming
solvers so we can find solutions faster
and it turns out that if we know a high
level structure if we know what
variables and constraints have we can do
much better here
there's also some very interesting
recent work on doing uh
model counting and belief propagation to
give us a form of inference
excuse me and um and as a replacement to
um v synthetic for
search heuristics it turns out if you if
you
know where most of the solutions are
likely to lie for any individual
constraint you can
really direct the search process in a
way that you can't if you're just
working in the saturn coding
so i'm going to stop there i hope i've
given
people some interesting things to talk
about
thank you so much that was definitely
very very interesting clubbing for
everybody
so quick questions comments
perhaps may i start
so as far as
i see it so um in a certain way so the
the generalized consistency is kind of
corresponds to what i had in my talk is
relative tree hardness one so that's the
kind of a correspondence although
exactly we don't have these constraints
obviously
um so and we did so but
we did quite quite a lot of experiments
also in this direction of
improving consistency and there we came
up to the
we had the following experimental
results which kind of
corresponds to to your current trends
in using more learning let's name it so
for example you look at
advanced encryption standard hard
cryptographic problems and so
that type of satsura which are called um
look ahead soldiers which i have a
certain similarity to
constraint solving algorithms so they
don't do learning or traditional ones
they um they learned
they learned they got a lot faster they
said
this is improved hardness of a lower
tartness of of
of of inputs however the cities also
didn't get anything out of that and now
so at least for
for certain uh um in certain cases we
could actually determine
for example we took the simple case of
two of a system of linear equations
xor constraints with two equations and
they actually have already a heart
very high tree hardness but a low width
hardness
and this i believe so perfectly
explained while it was very hard
for the satsuba but this um didn't
matter at all to the to the
cdcl servers they they cope with it
anyway so somehow
so that what might be one reason that
this r consistency is tree-like
corresponds in a certain way to
tree-like resolution while cdc also
works
they they already take advantage of a
certain they have they have more
attack-like
notions of hardness so that could be one
aspect here one could consider more
yes okay thanks
maybe a quick question um you mentioned
the
result that all different
can't be expressed in cnf in polynomial
space
i would expect that you don't allow
extension variables because
i would guess if you introduce extension
variables then this
should be possible i think
oliver might be the better person to
answer this question perhaps
that was in the pa part of my talk which
which i
did run very quickly through it but
basically so
it is of course not that you can you of
course you can express
all different in polynomial size but
it's the r consistency
so you want that whenever you apply a
partial assignment
to your encoding and the whole thing
gets unsatisfiable
then you want the uniqlos propagation or
any kind of
resolution also solves the problem and
that's the part that makes it hard and
then also this auxiliary variables
you can't do that and that's this very
interesting proof by this year at all
which shows by reducing the problem
to the lower bounds for for monotone
sockets so i found it
this i think one could do quite a bit
more here but
it's this quality it says that
unsatisfiability must be
catch caught quickly via unit gross
propagation or fate literal elimination
or
something like that that makes it
impossible thanks oliver i
understand this but my question was
whether this lower bound also holds
when you're allowed to use extension
variables
yes so that allows you you can arbitrary
because it's relative it's relative
hardness so there's no restriction at
all
on that so that doesn't help in this
case unfortunately
so do i understand correctly that the
problem here is that whatever encoding
you use
since all different if you give it the
pigeon hole
then all different will immediately
propagate to contradiction
like it is it would just look at the
pigeon hole instance and say onset
so whatever cnf encoding you have in
mind should also at top level unit
propagate to contradiction is is that a
correct understanding
yes and that sort of hints
why why it's hard to do i guess
yes so so so i have the argument that of
course you could just
implement a circuit which implements a
regas algorithm right for all different
and then you would have like a circuit
which would do the all different
constraint but you would probably need
additional decisions you wouldn't get it
by
just propagation i think this is the
right way to think about it right
look but if i make sure i mean the
problem is
you of course you can do some
computation you see you watch
your sat solver and uh and then of
course you can do it
of course because then you can just
simulate the all different
algorithm in any way but if you if it
just
the simple sub solver we just do this
resolution or something like that
then makes it it doesn't have this
ability to watch itself and say oh
we are having a different constraint
okay so thank you very very much
karen and um should we take maybe a
couple minutes break and then do the
showcase for a little bit of a time but
can i just ask a very short maybe basic
question
mm-hmm just one on slide 14 and 15
uh you mentioned this enumeration
approach really
three um what are very values in csp i'm
working with sub
okay um so you do have let's
let's think a very simple backtracking
search tree
um so you you reach a leaf node of this
search tree and there are there are two
reasons
you could have a leaf node um ivy you
have found
a solution so you found a satisfying
assignment
or you found some reason that the
sequence of decisions you've made so far
lead to unsatisfiability
um so what we're saying here is you will
never be in the state
where a sequence of decisions that you
make lead to
unsatisfiability okay so so any any
decision you make is going to lead to at
least one solution
so that makes sense make sense yes
thanks a lot fine
well i'll stay stay here
thank you